and he's like he's like you're afraid of
me huh and i was like i was like yeah
i'm afraid and he goes
that's your truth huh
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my all in it like
what's going on how was uh wednesday
uh it was good man ramon was on
so no you know ramon ramon is the best
so ramon came on and did his thing he
was the best good i'm uh i'm happy for
him he's getting a bunch of wins right
now and that makes me happy for him
yeah uh you where were you so you were
doing something interesting that's why
let me tell you come back tell us the
story
yeah let me tell you what i did so i
volunteer with this program called the
last mile it was started by my friend
chris redlitz chris started uh
he did a bunch of stuff he was early at
reebok so he's 65 years old he was an
early employee at reebok when he
probably
became very financially successful there
then he started a company that he took
public and then he started a vc fund
that i believe was quite successful they
were in on wish.com and a few other
things and he started this charity or
nonprofit called the last mile and the
whole vision behind this thing is
basically
um so i'm not supposed to use the word
inmates they've asked me not to use the
word inmates but sometimes i'm still
going to use that word because that's
what most people know what it means but
basically prison inmates
they are going to get out what do they
want you to say
well
and it's a good it's a good terminology
and good way of thinking but basically
they're like well look we're trying to
get them out of prison and into the
mindset of they're going to be working
and having a job we don't want to refer
to them as offenders as inmates but
students
but um but that would be confusing in
this context okay yeah in this context
yes and so i'm gonna kind of go against
his rules in this context so there's uh
something like a million people in
prison right and a lot of guys are there
for 10 20 30 years for manslaughter for
doing whatever
they're going to get out and whether you
like the whether you forgive them for
their crime or not the fact is is that
you they're going to get out and so the
last mile is teaching them how to code
for about two or three years through a
program and then helping them get jobs
at like slack i believe ebay things like
that
and they've graduated i think 800 people
out of prison who went through the
program and none of them have gone back
to prison and i believe the average
prison the average person who goes to
prison i think it's like a 65 chance
that they go back to prison right so the
fact is that these guys like for example
i was with this one guy who
uh basically he caught his wife cheating
and they got into an argument according
to the news i googled it
she like
went to fight him with a hammer he
grabbed the hammer and killed her
and he was in prison for 20 years and i
was hanging out with this guy which is
weird that's weird you know that's like
a mind and he was like yeah i'm
gonna get out in three years uh prior to
this i was an engineer or sorry i was a
sales person at a pharmaceutical company
i had a great job
and i'm learning how to do javascript
and mongodb so i can get a job at a tech
company hopefully because no one's going
to hire me unless i go through this
program
and that's crazy right isn't that weird
like i'm hanging out and i was with my
wife sarah we're walking around this
prison
just hanging out with these guys and i
get to know them and i'm like i would
hang i mean you're nice enough you're
right you get along fine i had no idea
you'd ever done this and they start
opening up and telling me what they did
and it's pretty amazing and it's amazing
for a couple reasons the first reason is
that um when you're in this like when
you're so some guys are just like
habitual criminals like i talked to this
one guy i was like what was your job
before this he was like oh i was a meth
dealer right i stole meth
and i killed the guy we went to rob this
house and i killed someone
and um
and i would but and he was like besides
killing them i was just like criminal i
just did all types of crazy but
once i learned how to do coding i
actually got more logical where i
realized that if i do this then this
other thing is going to happen and so i
started learning a lot about impulse
control and i started learning about
myself and so it's like learning how to
code but also learning about yourself
typing like an if then statement for
your life
yes and so that's quite fascinating the
second thing is you know there's not a
lot of black coders but unfortunately
there's a lot of black folks in prison
and so uh these guys are learning how to
code we are with we're in indiana it was
mostly white people but i've done this
in san quentin but um like for someone
who graduates and leaves jail and they
go back to an all-black neighborhood a
lot of times it's these these kids these
young kids it's the first time they're
gonna meet a programmer who's black and
who looks like them and so not only are
we helping these folks stay out of
prison but it's kind of cool that like
you know you're actually like helping
the diversity issue in tech and so
how the heck did this guy chris read
let's start this that seems so random
from like you know your employee at a
reebok and then you start a vc fund and
where did this come from
i i believe the story is 10 years ago he
was dating a woman and she volunteered
at a prison and she was teaching i think
math like she just got pulled into it at
san quentin she lived in san francisco
and someone was like hey we need like or
no sorry uh someone was like chris can
you come and talk about entrepreneurship
to these inmates right and he was like i
guess i'll go and he goes and they're
like can you come again can you come
again he's like uh i guess and then
eventually he was like wow you know this
is a major problem uh that i'm
passionate and i care about and so him
and his wife they started a thing where
they go hey um they went to uh
sacramento the the capital of california
and they basically lobbied for this
program they go hey everyone we'll put
up the hundred thousand dollars uh you
know they're talking to the politicians
would it would be okay if we did a
cohort for entrepreneurship in san
quentin and they like through friends of
friends they got in front of the right
people and it approved and then they're
like well you know entrepreneurship is
okay but teaching them how to code is
way better right and so he starts doing
that and then he goes and convinces
apple
the i believe the trump the trump
administration uh the koch brothers uh
rich people to donate money and now they
have this like huge program
that's kind of amazing they've trained
some huge number of people right like
there are a lot of people in this
program is that right
yeah they've got i believe that they
only allow like 20 or 30 people per like
cohort and they have like 15 prisons
doing it by the way if you're listening
to this
well they graduated i think a thousand
people and i was gonna say by the way if
you're listening to this i'm getting
some of these numbers wrong um i didn't
like write all this down so
whatever i'm saying divide by two and
multiply by two so i think they have
like a thousand people but let me tell
you something that's interesting so i
was in this prison
and you want to know what's crazy dude
most everyone was really fat and out of
shape
and yeah as a fitness influencer you
just you couldn't you couldn't help
yourself
well here's why this is interesting to
me so i was talking to chris and i was
like you know everyone was like fat and
like the food that they give these folks
it's horrible it was like white bread
and bologna and like generic like oreo
cookies and you could buy stuff but he
was like yeah well you know at some of
the longer maximum
uh
maximum security prisons they're a
little bit more fit but yeah it's a huge
problem and in china i was like chris
like if we gave these guys like look
there i understand like the idea of like
you committed a crime you sacrifice
privileges whatever but i think if we
just gave them like some better meat and
vegetables for every meal and forced
them to exercise like you've got to get
up at 7 a.m and as a prison we're gonna
do jumping jacks push-ups calisthenics
and like you know it's like the military
i think they would behave better and
ultimately like if your body works
better you're gonna maybe behave and act
a little bit better and he was like yeah
you know i think i agree but even in
american prisons you can't force people
to do anything it's like against the law
or against the rules
but i started thinking about this and
and i and i think that's kind of
interesting and they do this in china
and he was like yeah we uh we like got
some we like saw chinese prisons and
everyone shredded because they make you
do this wow
uh okay
did you know i've done a very similar
thing so i got a couple of
uh like when you said you were doing
this i i like
remembered back when i did this so
there's a group in the bay area that
does this called the inside inside
circle i think it's called and um
nonprofit they basically go into it's
like a men's group so for people who
listen to this that don't know what a
men's group is uh it's a idea that's
been around for a long time there's many
different flavors of this there's some
that are like kind of business oriented
there's some that are uh oriented around
just changing your life i forgot what's
the what's the famous one of the barrier
that people think is a cult that's like
a men's group uh i don't know if you
know the name of it it's like a weekend
it's like a weekend thing you do uh but
there's a whole bunch of water or
something yeah something like that uh
not not that but there's something like
that
so anyways a men's group is where a
bunch of men get together they sit in a
circle and they talk about their
feelings and they talk about what's
going on and they
and they have like a whole process
that's like basically helps people
unpack what's going on inside so that
they
when you unpack what's going on inside
you're not carrying all this baggage
around and then you you will act more
like the way you want to act because you
don't have this sort of suppressed and
pent-up stuff inside that's my like
layman's version of i'm sure there's a
much fancier better way of explaining it
so i went to folsom prison did the same
same sort of thing two-day program you
go in i met this guy gino he was kind of
like you know you get a pen pal buddy
basically so
you know you meet your buddy and he was
in there he's been in there since he was
18.
and he had murdered somebody when he was
18 and he's like been in there for 20
years now so he's 38 and he was like you
know yeah i did this horrible thing when
i was 18 and like i'm in here for life
basically like my whole life is
basically in prison and uh he had a
great
great attitude about him funny guy and
he was you know he was just
it was kind of unreal um
because i had been you know kind of
embarrassed to admit it but i had been
kind of uh
you know in my head i just sort of wrote
this off like i just wrote off people in
prison like i think society writes them
off and i had sort of just thought like
yeah i'm not super interested in going
in and meeting people who have murdered
people before um
but you know it's really not that simple
once you meet them
it's really not that simple um to sort
of like bucket people like that as good
and bad and so you know kind of
you know it's kind of embarrassing to
even say it out loud it sounds obvious
but you know it was kind of a
i don't know this kind of awakening
moment and then we we did these
exercises so we did these exercises
where you're like
you know you sit in your little group
and you talk about what's going on
and it's so funny because it was
basically half
successful tech guys and then half
people from folsom prison and uh and
they would be like you know the tech guy
is like oh you know
um
you know just a stereotype for a second
like my kids trying to get into this
private school the admissions process my
wife is really blah blah and then like
the next guy who's like you know
um i haven't seen my daughter in 25
years and i just hope she's okay and i
heard something heard something happen
to her and i'm not able to help and it's
just gutting me
and then the tech guy is like you know
my company we raised our a we're just
trying to raise our b like
it was like it's so funny like real
problems fake problems real problems
fake problems and uh but like this is
sort of like no judgment right that's
the idea is like um actually it's funny
the guys who lead you in there they're
very like sort of wise people there
there's one guy bj who runs the program
and then uh i forgot the name of the
other guy he's an awesome guy and he's
like he's like recognized as a shaman in
like seven different civilizations in
africa like this guy is just a beast in
all ways they in fact they call his
nickname is beastmaster because he sort
of is able to tame the beasts in the
prison um and he's got this like
presence about him that he wouldn't
believe like imagine ray lewis he does
volunteer
he was in prison but he was in prison he
got out and then he you know devoted his
life to this work um
and he's like sort of one of the most
wise guys ever and he said this early on
he's like
uh you know let's set some ground rules
before we go in here man like okay what
are we and one guy was like you know no
judgment i want to be going here i don't
want to judge the guys in there
he goes
okay so we're going to lie to ourselves
and he's like what what do you mean he's
like he's like you're going to make a
judgment
uh
when somebody says something or does
something the brain is instantaneously
going to make a judgment and you can sit
there and say no no i'm not doing it i
don't want to do it
you can try to resist it but you're
going to fail he goes instead let's just
agree to this
you'll make the judgment but just agree
to this the judgment says more about you
than it does about them
he's like so just use that that reaction
to teach you about yourself don't use it
to define the other people in there
that's something that i still use to
this day kind of like in every every
walk of life uh because it's it's so
true um
so anyways i had this like crazy
experience in there so i was uh i was
talking
or i guess like
i don't know if i should even tell the
story but basically i
when i went in there was one guy in
there that just looked like the baddest
dude in the prison he was wearing his
sunglasses nobody else was wearing
sunglasses he had like a cane he wasn't
the strongest or the biggest but you
could tell he had the respect of
everybody in there and almost like the
fear like a fear version of respect or
at least that's what i perceived because
you know you go into the situation you
sort of quickly scope it out and you're
trying to like understand the lay of the
land and so instantaneously my brain's
judgment was that's the baddest dude in
here like don't piss that guy off don't
say the wrong thing in front of that
person uh he kind of scares me and of
course as fate would have it we get into
a group of four we get matched up and
he's my buddy in the group of four
and this guy basically i was you know so
then you're supposed to like again talk
about your problems and i was kind of
conscious to be like okay i'm not gonna
talk about these like first world
problems so i tried to say some
that was like deeper than that but he
saw straight through it because these
people have a very good you know
detector and uh he was like
he's like man you're just saying what we
want to hear he just cut me off like two
minutes in oh that's bad and i was in
the middle of my big kind of like
heartfelt thing and i'm a good talker
i'm a good storyteller i'm a good liar
frankly um and he immediately was like
man don't come in here and just say what
we want to hear
and i was like oh and then i'm like
my the guy i was already afraid of is
now calling me out specifically for
basically one of the worst things you
could do in these situations which is be
inauthentic
and be fake it's like you didn't you
really didn't have to do anything that
was the one thing just don't be fake uh
and i was i was being vague and this guy
called me out on it he's like what you
really thinking
and i was like and i just said what was
on my mind i go
um
i go i really just don't want to sound
like an idiot in front of you
and he starts laughing and he goes he
goes you afraid of me i was like yeah
i'm afraid hey i'm afraid here he goes
so if i get closer you'll be afraid he
gets closer closer he gets right up to
my face like one inch from my face
and he's like he's like you afraid of me
huh and i was like i was like yeah i'm
afraid and he goes
that's your truth huh i go yeah
he goes
i go yeah i'm like in my head i'm like
oh okay i think i did it right i just
said well i was thinking of that i think
you know and so then the brain the voice
in my head that was like judging every
word i was saying kind of like relaxed
for a second because this guy put him at
ease and he was like
he's like he's like i can respect that
and he's like uh
and he's he starts telling a story about
like his life when he was afraid and
like you know i'm off the hook i go sit
down now
and uh and at the end the guy like you
know basically gave me a hug on the way
out and he was like you know uh he's
like i hope i see you again sometime and
i was like wow that was a just like a
little
life moment that
it doesn't like i'm telling the story
now i don't think this even means
anything to anybody but i remember this
like it like it happened yesterday and
there's very few moments in my life that
i can remember so vividly but this was
one of them and i think it's because it
was like a primal moment where i didn't
know what was going to happen there was
real fear you talk about this a lot like
we're very rarely in real danger
situations and even though this wasn't
actual danger this guy wasn't gonna do
anything to me
it definitely felt that way and i
remember it
and the crazy part and we can move on
for this but the crazy part is like i
think what separates you and me or
anyone listening to this podcast which
by the way i learned well i'll talk
about a second what separates us from
someone like these folks like
i met a bunch of people who were like
habitual criminals they were like yeah
you know i just like i was a drug addict
or i was just i hated authority and i've
changed but i was young and mean and i
met a bunch of other people who work i
met a guy who worked at abbott i met a
guy who worked at ford i met a guy who
as engineers like you know they're
probably making six figures and they go
my marriage
went horrible one of us cheated and i
got into a fist fight and i killed
someone or i hurt someone really badly
and i was like i don't think i'm ever
gonna like hurt someone
but i could like it's not like in a
thing of rage like you could flip out or
i could get drunk and kill someone and
driving you know like you could and it's
not that cr we're not that different
some of these guys and so that was
really crazy and while there so
let's get we'll talk about business
there's this there's
these guys have like ipads they're not
apple but they're like a different brand
of like i ipad type like tablet okay and
um you can be an approved podcast
and so if we go through this the process
of getting approved we can go in there
and there's about and there's about a
million incarcerated folks in america
and there's not that many podcasts on
this on this thing
i was like oh i was like dude let's
boost our numbers and so i'm working um
with the right people there's like a
company that makes these like
amazing and and we're going to be called
microsoft and it's a surface the
microsoft manager system shambles as you
keep calling it an ipad
dude i looked it up on on wikipedia it's
this company and they were they sold to
a pe company for two billion dollars and
they basically make things that the
prison
gives to right you know incarceration
they can buy they can like buy movies
and and uh you basically if you
have enough money on your accounts you
can watch movies your entire stay and so
uh
anyway it was kind of cool so that's my
story i have a related thing do you know
the guy mike posner
of course the musician so he i know who
he is yeah so he's like kind of like
rapper singer type dude i i took a pill
and ibiza that's like i took a pill at
ibiza cooler than me he's got a couple
big big big big songs
he went to duke right he went to duke so
he was there while i was there we were
in the same year and uh and i remember
meeting him or seeing him and he said
this white kid he said he's gonna be a
white kid from detroit who said he's
gonna be a rapper i was like all right
like eminem like you know that's who
goes to duke yeah like you went to duke
yeah that's not really the path my
friend um but he killed it he did
amazing and actually like one of the
things i remember from that was
he released his song
on itunes u
um because he was in school so he only
somebody only a student or professor
could put content on itunes u which was
like the subsection of itunes and
because most of the things that go up
there are like extremely academic right
this is like a lecture from this random
biology class in at duke so now all of a
sudden you get this like rap song that
goes on itunes u and he hit the top of
the charts on itunes u and he would tell
so he put out there like yo i'm number
one on itunes you know like parentheses
yeah yeah
and so
that's how i think he got booked on at
first that's how he got a lot of college
it's like a growth hack like a lot of
college students heard his song because
itunes u had like uh
like there was like the rankings it's
like show the top 10 itunes songs which
is super competitive you got to be like
mega famous to do that and then right
below it was top 10 itunes u downloads
and his was number one and so i think he
got a lot of fans that way and then he
booked a bunch of early gigs when he had
no name to say by saying yeah i'm number
one on college campuses on itunes and
they were like well okay that sounds
decent all right well we'll give you a
shot and that's and then he went on a
college tour and that's how he built his
following so he did a very similar thing
to what you're talking about
that's badass i i like him a lot so
that's a good that's a good story it's
like it's like bjork getting famous in
iceland or something like it's better to
be like have like a local maximum like
to be famous on a local on a local level
and then you leverage that
well one more quick prison one before we
switch off that so um so my buddy did my
best friend trevor did this thing called
a book storm which i think is a great
idea in general which is he wanted to
write a book and so he's like all right
books normally take a long time what if
i did it differently he's like so let me
um
he did like a quick not a draft but like
just a quick like kind of concept of the
book and then he flew out the five most
badass people he knew
and he put us all up in a hotel and he
said
i want you here for basically a day and
a half to just help me think through
this book
and he's like we'll brainstorm it
together and he's like i think if i just
do this with deep intensity i can make
way more progress than if i just kind of
like lightly touch this book every day
for like two years yeah for two years
and it totally works name what's
trevor's last name reagan uh r-a-g-a-n
so he uh so he and now he has the book
it's coming out it did like
for what he called like a patio book
it's like a podcast of the audi of the
book or something like that so um
anyways he flew out it was me because i
was like his best friend from college
and then it was like this person who was
like the um
the the olympic coach for the women's
volleyball team and so the us u.s
women's volleyball has just kicked ass
internationally which is
not expected because volleyball is a
much bigger sport in other countries but
this guy like turned the program around
and like so he was amazing he was there
and this one guy was there
and he had been in prison for 20 years
and he had gotten out and he trevor does
a lot of uh pro bono like talking in
prisons and so he had met this guy in
the process and he was like wow this is
this guy's amazing and this guy shared
two things so i was like he came out and
i was like man this guy's like he is so
wise he is so articulate i feel like
he's read every book because he
keeps referencing
really insightful pieces from all these
different books and so i was like what's
your story man he's like actually i was
in prison for 20 years i was like whoa
no and he goes you know i said so
you read all these books while you're
there he goes he goes yeah he goes my
first year when i was there i was like i
was 20 years old or something like that
he's like i decided
uh i'm gonna see what i want to see he
goes so i i decided like you said
they're calling they're called them
students there hey that's what he did
that's that's what he did for himself
and his brain he goes i told myself i'm
not in prison i'm in university he's
like and every day i woke up i said i
have i'm getting a 20-year phd in life
he said every day i woke up and i just
everybody around me in the line we're
getting food out this is this is the
student union i'm at the student union
i'm getting food from the from the from
the mule hall i'm going to the library i
am in university right now i am not in
prison he just literally like worked
himself up into a frenzy where his mind
only saw that and he saw everything as
as university so he read all these
different books and then similarly he
said you know i would look around on the
on the yard and on the yard you'd see
all kinds of bad going on you know
the black guys fighting the white guys
and the mexican guys and all that and
you'd see broken you know just broken
down you know our basketball hoop was
half crooked all that
and he's like i just played a game every
day in my mind i would change what i saw
so i would see a beautiful green field i
would see he's like every day he's like
if i saw a broken glass i would see
roses and this guy's mindset impressed
me so much it's another one that stuck
with me which was like
create your own reality and like how
many times if this guy could do that in
prison then when i'm waiting in line at
starbucks i'm not waiting in line bored
i change it in my head just like the guy
changed his university things that was
another one that was like that's amazing
a huge life thing that i took away from
that guy
dude i love this prison talk we we
should
i gotta we got i think we should do like
an entire episode on this there's like
all these guys who are blowing up on
youtube who like are it's all about
crime and and and prison talk and and
whatnot and i learned so much from those
folks
do you watch these videos that's
basically like a guy
these are not insightful and
deep but they're just entertaining to me
have you seen these ones where guys will
go they'll film around a police station
and then the cop comes out and he's like
hey why are you filming man what are you
what are you doing here let me see your
license let me see your id
he's like nope i'm not going to show you
my idea and he's like what he's like let
me see your idea watch that all the
time and he's like no i know my rights
i'm in a public place i'm allowed to
film he's like yeah but
what are you doing here he's like do you
not know the rights and they just like
talk back to cops and there's something
about this about just talking back to
cops
it's called justice porn and it's just
exactly like
it's just this porn that's what i call
it it's like and the comments are super
polarized half the people are like what
an dude you're just making
you're just being annoying to the cops
they're like you're provoking them
and then they take the bait and then you
like jump on them with because you you
why did you spend your day doing this
and then the other half people are sort
of like me and they're like god i don't
know why i find this so entertaining i
just love when somebody's like it's just
like knows their accident yeah
there's something to it man i can't i
can't resist that's my joke that's my
new reality tv yeah go to uh reddit.com
justiceporn and there's a whole
subreddit for that and there's like a
million subscribers it's pretty crazy
yeah it's not like there'll be a guy
gets pulled over and he's like let me
see your id and he shows him a password
from another country and he's like
uh no i need your id he's like no you
don't there's a treaty that says if i
show you this password blah blah blah
and you cannot arrest me and he's like
no some random ass like loophole and
he's just driving around fast hoping to
get pulled over just so he can do this
thing on camera and get a bunch of views
it's kind of sick but i like it
speaking of other countries let me tell
you about something
interesting have you heard of prosper
have you heard of prospero
pera sounds very familiar what is it
okay so i almost or i'm in the process
and i hope i can make it happen of
investing in this company called
uh mini circle
so
prospero is this new like private
charter city we've talked about private
charter cities a bunch right okay
and so it was set up in part by peter
thiel who's a very controversial weirdo
type of guy i like him but a lot of
people don't um and so he basically set
up this country or the city in honduras
and they have their own rules and their
own laws and weird things like that so
do you know what gene therapy is have
you heard of gene therapy yeah is it
basically uh like is crit would crispr
be part of gene therapy so it's
basically the modification of your dna
in order to like fight disease is that a
good description yeah so it's this very
experimental kind of technique kind of
like medical procedure where basically
you insert and modify genes in order to
uh
in order to replace surgeries or drugs
so for example there was this kid in
syria he had some weird disorder where
like all this skin started
deteriorating he was about to die and
they did this gene editing stuff and he
was able to regrow back his skin
and a lot of people but it's very
controversial because you're doing a
couple things you're kind of like
playing god which uh i don't buy in but
that's an argument and also
yeah and people don't like it and also
it's experimental and so the fda like
very closely monitors this stuff and
they'll say like yeah and so there's and
there's a lot of like weird like
biohacker fringe types who are
interested in this stuff and so it's all
like
controversial kind of but nonetheless
it's cool so i'm trying to invest in
this company called mini circle and
they're making this new gene therapy
that like increases muscle mass bone
density helps you uh with insulin
sensitivity and does all this like crazy
to you but in order to get it done
in america you got to go to the fda and
it's like this big process and so
they've moved their company to prospero
this peter teal
city in order to make all this
happen and they're doing their existing
floating city
or just in honduras
and so they're doing it like so
basically they're like we're working
with fully informed and trusted i'm
reading off something we're working with
fully informed and trusted study
participants who are choosing to do this
right but
it we couldn't get this done in america
it would take 40 years to do this we're
going to do this on this lane on this
weird city type of thing
and i'm trying to invest in this company
i think it's ridiculous i think it's
crazy but
kind of cool
it is very cool i invested in one
charter city called uh praxis and there
what they did was pretty smart they were
like they first created just a bunch of
like um like a group here in america so
they invited a bunch of cool people from
new york la san francisco and they're
just like host events so they'll throw
dope parties so these people they're
like in a community they get to meet
each other at these events and there's
like an online component and they keep
doing this they keep doing this and
meanwhile they're searching they're
going around to like all around the
world and they're basically negotiating
with governments and they're saying hey
give us some free land
and let us have our own rule of law and
rule of financial law um
in like our own financial regulations
and our own rule of law in this zone
we're going to create a new city and
we're going to bring all these people
like cool people plus like development
dollars to your place right so
in the u.s you could never say hey us
government go give us you know a little
piece of wyoming they're not really
going to give you that but um you know
you go to whatever you know you go just
in the mediterranean or the balkans and
you find some random piece of land you
say oh this is beautiful it's right on
the ocean it's undeveloped and you go to
the government you say look what if i
could get a bunch of uh people from
america you know successful people who
want
to kind of live in a new a new charter
city and uh and so it's like really wild
moonshot idea i totally fully expect
this investment to go to zero
i put in a very small check but i had to
participate because the founder was so
convinced that like yeah of course
people will do this and uh and that if
you did it it would be very large it'd
be like owning the raw land you know
you know the land under manhattan where
all the buildings are going to get built
and you can either do development
yourself or you could sell off the pads
and make a ton of money so the business
is great if you can kick off a new
charter city and one of the ways you
attract people is this like if you own
if you have your own rule of law you can
say hey
biohackers come here because you're
allowed to do you know you're allowed to
run your experiments here because we
have our own kind of like free zone
where we can do our own and so uh i
think it's really cool what's happening
biology is pretty convinced that in the
next 10 years we're going to see charter
cities uh you know pop-up startup cities
yeah and on one hand to say to explain
why this like why the haters exist on
this um and why i i definitely hate on
them a little bit or you know there's
like some negativity which is like it's
most likely like fringe libertarian
types kind of like how all the bitcoin
rich folks are going to puerto rico to
avoid taxes you know you could say like
the fda exists for a good reason rules
exist for a good reason you guys are
freaks just trying to like avoid the
reality um and there's definitely a
truth to that and there are like
probably that's a solid argument
some parts of that and then on the other
side you can say well like that's like
what the
america started right yeah you know we
bailed on we were we were the free
experimentation zone right yeah like we
rode a ship across like uh you know 3000
miles not knowing what to expect and we
just landed and we figured it out so
i think even the people who like startup
cities would say yeah great there should
be the fda there should be all this
stuff for most people in most places but
if it covers all all land and all people
within a country then you stamp out the
experiment wild experimentation so i
know that google guys have been talking
about this before which is that they
need a there should be a free space
where if you opt in you can go and you
can do some of the experimental things
that you can't do here and the learnings
from that let's say nine out of the ten
things don't work out or they have bad
consequences okay fine but if one
breakthrough innovation or um or
discovery is made then that can be
exported back to the mainland we can say
look let's go let's take this through
proper testing and let's roll it out to
everybody so like you know people go
to germany to go get you know stem cell
treatments and things like that because
it's not legal here but in other
countries they're more liberal about it
so like you know i started a company
once a biotech company and the
technology was made in the u.s the
government us government had funded 40
million dollars of r d for this
technology
but you couldn't go use it in anywhere
in the us because the like you would
never get the permits the people would
say why would we will not let you put
these microbes into the ground it was
basically these little micro bugs that
could eat coal underground so you don't
have to mine it and they would basically
just like fart or breathe out natural
gas so they will just mine the coal
themselves and you just collect the
natural gas you don't have to frack the
earth and you don't have to mine the
coal but the us would never let us pump
these microbes into the ground because
they're like
we don't have to we're life is pretty
good here we don't have to do that so we
went to indonesia and we went to india
where they were like
yeah hey here's a huge plot of land how
much money do you need to go do this we
love this right we want economic
activity we want innovation and if this
works then we want to capture some of
the upside of being able to like sell
this technology to others and so we got
quick permits in indonesia and india
where we couldn't you know the company's
trying to do the same thing in the us
they were bogged down for years and
never got approvals
have you ever heard of medical tourism
yeah i've always been curious about like
how how people have the guts to do this
but it makes sense you go to mexico and
get your teeth fixed or whatever you
know have you ever done anything like
this no so for those who don't know what
this is i learned about this because me
and sean's buddy john howard you're
friends with john howard yeah yeah he's
great
we i shared an office with him at this
place called founders dojo and they
created a company i forget the name of
it but it was basically medical tourism
so basically um i i think a a use case
is typically like dentists or like
veneers and teeth stuff although then
there's other stuff like breast implants
and uh plastic surgery where their
premise was basically it's cheaper to
get it done in bali or mexico or india
somewhere like that where like they're i
have no idea if this is true they're
like the doctors are just as good but
it's a fraction of the cost to fly out
there
get the surgery done and chill there for
a week and recover and fly back the
company did not work out and frankly in
my opinion it sounds like a pain
in the ass i would never do that i'd
rather pay twenty thousand dollars in
america for veneers but be able to get
it done like three blocks from my house
then i would want to go to mexico but
well yeah it's not for you right it's
for somebody who can't afford it here
it's it's not if i could do this or that
it's i can't do this and my teeth
hurt i can't do this and i need
this surgery done
uh okay if i can't afford it here even
with insurance
then okay i'll go to mexico and i'll do
it because i have no no real other
option all right it's so prohibitively
expensive it would me
financially
and i don't want to save my health and
my finances so i'm going to do
this there's i think it's a hundred
billion dollars a year
is paid off
it's 100 billion of medical tourism per
year globally
that amazes me i never would have
thought that i know i just think because
it seems that's what i'm saying in the
ass it seems wild right but i think
that's the
you know when people are pushed into a
corner they will find a way you know
that that is sort of the the innovation
of people um and yeah i'm actually
surprised this thing didn't work what he
was doing was he was selling leads so he
would find customers who were interested
in it he would educate them and he would
sell those leads to the off medical
offices
you know in mexico or wherever and say
hey this person is interested they want
to do a phone call with you would you
pay us 100 for that lead and they were
like yeah sure you know and i i honestly
think that business should have worked
and would have worked had he stuck with
it it was like a pivot and maybe he
didn't have enough time to figure it out
yeah i don't i don't know the
particulars but i know that it's when he
told me about it i was like there's no
way this would work but
i say that about a lot of stuff
yeah exactly
all right what else you want to talk
about
i don't know what do you want to do uh
let me look at your list here okay so
there's uh julian building of ranch i
think that's pretty cool and we should
talk about that
uh let's do julian building a ranch and
then let's do uh let's do that okay i
have a
good deep dive but i'm gonna save it for
the next episode that's a good one about
the diamond industry
all right lay the background of this so
you know julian better than i do right
yeah yeah so julian shapiro he's just at
julian on twitter
a lot of people follow him there i think
he's got like you know 200 000 or maybe
more followers he's a weirdo total
weirdo in the best way possible um yeah
he called me the other day and i said i
go hello and he goes the love of my life
like check my phone who the is
calling me and then he's like i have
this deal blah blah blah and then he you
know just go straight into it doesn't
even acknowledge the love of my life
part uh it was just hilarious he's just
a hilarious character he sends us like
the funniest memes like on twitter he's
like this really thoughtful intellectual
like guy who'll teach you how to write
and teach you about all this other stuff
teach you how to think frameworks blah
blah blah and then in our group chat
he's sending you know the the goofiest
memes which is uh like that's my
favorite type of person who's got both
of those sides to him the silly side and
the smart side so he tweeted out that
he's basically he's been talking about
this for a while so it's not just like a
thing but he's like
he really really wants to build a ranch
actually by the way i should share the
most interesting thing about him for the
last eight months
all he has eaten
is wag you steak and boiled eggs
which i don't believe
i believe it because he's crazy and he
he kind of needed to i think he had
something like his his gut health wasn't
right and he just like took control he's
like i'm gonna i'm gonna figure out how
to fix this the doctor's not helping me
i'm gonna fix this myself he had read
about the carnivore diet i think jordan
peterson had a very similar
like kind of like issue and he famously
came out so i did carnivor it healed me
basically and so he started doing it he
started feeling a little better then he
committed to it he's like okay so he
literally orders wagyu steak
from these like farm from this one farm
actually in particular and he orders
like three thousand dollars a month of
steak and he shows me his freezer his
freezer is just full of bricks of steak
like
imagine like you know when you see in a
movie
piles of cash like just bound up
thousands of cash it's that but with
wagyu stakes and so he had like he said
he said it was miserable for like six or
eight weeks he was like i craved carbs i
craved sugar and then he got six eight
weeks into it and he's like i can't even
imagine eating sugar carbs again i i
don't crave them at all it sounds
horrible but by the way that's a real
thing from what i understand that
there's
basically in your microbiome in your gut
there's all these uh you know basically
there's bacteria that live there and the
bacteria feed the different yeasts and
bacterias feed off of
uh different like substrate different
different food and so the more you eat
carbs so imagine if what you're putting
in is carbs the bacteria that thrived
off of let's call it meat are going to
sort of die out and the bacteria that
thrive on carbs are going to like
proliferate they're going to spread
they're going to multiply and they're
going to um they're going to make up the
majority of your gut and then if you
decide to switch and go low carb all of
a sudden those bacteria are going to say
where the hell's our food and the in the
craving you feel those carb cravings is
not just like your mind being weak it's
literally the gut bacteria that are
signaling to your body we need our fix
we need our we're gonna die dude
what are you are you reading about body
stuff now how do you know all this uh no
well i heard this once i was fascinated
by it and somebody had told me this and
i looked into it because i was like is
that and like i'll just say
half the i read five years later
turns out to be so like with
health i feel like nobody knows anything
but
in hearing this i was like oh that makes
total sense and that's how you get you
know just like you get withdrawal pangs
if you stop caffeine
the same exact thing happens with carbs
and when you know that that's what's
happening you're like oh okay i just
need to ride you out like
i just need to keep i just need to hold
you i'll starve you guys out and in
seven days you'll be dead and the only
bacteria left will be the ones that feed
that like the stuff i i want to be
eating so it's a total thing
well okay so and back to julian and by
the way that's always why i wanted to
start my startup called hostage where we
just like take you and uh throw you in
this like like land and uh keep you in a
cabin for like three weeks and just like
monitor exactly a guaranteed weight loss
program would you yes would you be
interested in a 10-day program that
would guarantee results i will i will
pay you a hundred thousand dollars if
you don't lose weight
it sounds good we just give you 1400
calories a day welcome to hostage and
yeah yeah
yeah like would you like a glass of
water uh like that's all that's all you
get
one of your top 10 ideas
um
so anyway so julian basically yeah he
buys it and by the way the ranch thought
he was a restaurant because he was
ordering so much steak they were
like well
certainly you're a restaurant here's
your like wholesale price break and it
just turns out he's just a dude anyway
so he really wants to build this ranch
in the middle of nowhere because he's
thinking about where do i want to live
and then he tweeted out this thread that
i love and just just search his name
julian and i'm building a ranch in the
middle of nature and basically he's like
you know why am i doing this i want to
leave san francisco
i um you know i just think it would be
amazing and he basically tweets out his
plans he's like here's where i'm looking
here's the land here's how much it cost
i'm gonna build this like these like
prefab homes i'm gonna build this
podcast studio i'm gonna have like my
blank you like this i know this is like
right up your alley so what did you
think about this
okay so
this is in my opinion very romanticized
incredibly not practical and it won't
work in most cases have you ever been
uh you know you live and you lived in a
city for a long time you now live in the
burbs but it's still populated with
people have you ever been by yourself
for a while like in in uh rural areas
shoot me yeah horrible it's fun for a
minute it's great i was just in hawaii
and it was like this is relaxing this is
great
i can't i think that you basically you
want to do it to the point where you're
like i felt the benefits and now i want
to run back into society and tell
everyone how awesome i am for doing this
retreat from society
yes and so like i'm reading the teddy
roosevelt biography and he did the same
thing so basically um his wife and
mother died on the same day and it was
tragic it was horrible and while she the
wife died allison while giving birth to
his daughter so like the most
complicated day ever and he was like the
light of my life is gone i cannot live
anymore uh
just
life is done for me and so he went and
he bailed and he lived in the badlands
which is in the dakotas and he said i
feel replenished i feel wonderful but
you still gotta get he went eventually
back to dc and or new york and became a
politician and i think that i think what
a lot of people
overestimate is or rather underestimate
is community
so in order to make this work i think a
few people can make this work but for
nine out of ten folks you need peers you
need family you need friends life is i
don't give a if i live in the most
beautiful place on earth if i don't have
people that i can see on a regular basis
who i love
it's stupid i'd rather live poor and in
a shack with people i love than in a
mansion on a 50
50 acre 100 acre plot of land that's
beautiful
100 agree i think um
part of his plan is to basically have a
bunch of basically guest house and make
it an awesome ranch where he'll just
have this rotation of kind of friends
and cool people that want to come stay
and i think that will i think that will
happen uh but he's i think he's single
so i don't think you know if i went out
there with my wife my kids then i think
i could last a lot longer than than if i
went out there literally by myself um
even just hoping kind of friends would
come to visit so i think that is one
thing and i think this is a great
example of you want to have this dream
but then i think you need to test it i
think you need to go live i think he
should stop right now he should go
somewhere for one week and just say okay
let me go test or two weeks let me go
spend two weeks by myself in this airbnb
in the middle of nowhere and let me just
see how i feel after two weeks and then
let me try that again and i know he's
got the discipline because if you can
eat steak only for you know steak and
eggs only for
props but like you don't want it to feel
like an endurance contest if you're
trying to choose your lifestyle you want
it to be one that feels effortlessly
awesome not
like uh a a test of your mental
fortitude i think so i think it's
amazing i would love to go visit but i
would not want to do this myself
so i've actually like done this a bunch
of times so there's a bunch of stuff
that i wanted in my life
and i was able to test it on a very
small scale and i'll give you a few
examples so for example um
i wanted to retire and so i had the
opportunity a couple years ago i took
six weeks off right and i just took it
off completely and by the fifth week i
was like i can't retire i have to be
around i have to have something to do
another example is buying a fancy car
you can go and test these cars for
right it's a lot of money it's a
thousand dollars a day but you could
testing a 200 000 car for two days is
might you you get into it you're like
this ferrari is so small i cannot drive
this up and down like a driveway it's
just going to smack the ground and it's
not fun yeah i'm stressed about this and
the fun of having it versus the stress
of having it is actually not a good
trade now that i feel it i know it
another example is having a 5 000 square
foot home for the longest time i was
like i want a 5 000 square foot house so
i went and rented a 5 000 square foot
house i spent a lot of money maybe i
think i did it in new york i rented a 5
500 square foot house and it was like 13
000 for a month a lot of money no doubt
about that but the house was way more
expensive than that and i got in this
house and i was like i i cannot imagine
having to fix all this crap all the time
this is exhausting i can't do this i
don't want this or i'm i'm only using
the living room the bedroom and this
huge kitchen which i like i don't need
these six other bedrooms and
anyway i think that you could actually
test a lot of stuff and more people
should do that they should they you know
dude so i i okay i'm gonna rant for a
second think about like in college right
so i think there's this
crazy thing in society which is like
over commitment and over specialization
without dabbling so like you're a
freshman i remember at the end of my
freshman year in college i had to commit
to a major like dude i just figured out
like where the hell the bathroom is i
don't know what a major is i don't know
what the other majors could be i know
that if i don't commit i'm going to be
falling behind and off track and i'm not
going to have my credits on time and i'm
not going to know what courses to take
and i'm basically picking my career
without ever even knowing what my career
should be so forget what classes i'm
going to like these
my major sort of dictates what job i'm
eligible for at the end and i think it's
crazy and the same thing with people's
you know like first job they just sort
of pick a career track without dabbling
and figuring out what they actually
might like to do the like the idea of
dating is
amazing like my parents were arranged
marriage so they you know they literally
my mom read an ad in the newspaper for
my dad which said like you know six feet
tall which is a slight lie you know he's
5 10. uh you know
indian um what else engineer degree and
good family i was basically at the ad
and she was like described like every
indian american good enough good enough
to marry uh let's let's meet and then
they the parents met and they're like
okay
in this one tea we're having together
this one coffee meeting we're having all
right cool done deal uh see you the next
time i see you will be at the wedding um
and that's how they got married and like
you know really
shocker that you know these marriages
aren't always the best and so that are
they happy
uh no most so i would say like indie
marriages have like a very low divorce
rate because like societally it's like
like there's like a taboo against
getting divorced so they just like even
worse stay together unhappy is what most
people do and then obviously some get
divorced but like this arranged marriage
ideas it's not great now the
counterpoint would be
you know i think in new york there's a
53 divorce rate also so you know maybe
the whole dating thing doesn't work as
well so that's that's a fair
counterpoint but
i would say this idea of dating of
basically try before you buy
is um is really important in life and
like these tests that you've done for
yourself are super important and i'm
shocked more people don't do them i
started doing them and i'm like wow
that's way better than
this like i'll just have this idea in my
head and it'll get so real in my head
and then when i finally do it i'm like
oh that was underwhelming it's like
couldn't i have just sampled this
beforehand and known that and not have
this idea like um
uh what's an example
uh like okay i'll give you an example on
the plus side so example the plus so i
hired a chef so i have a personal chef i
wanted a personal chef for a really long
time
how much does that cost a month so
um how much does it cost me a month it's
about 3
400 a month uh 3 500 maybe
uh 3500 that includes food
that does not include the food no the
food's on top uh that's just like the
service the service of having a private
chef in my house and uh
by the way
worth it amazing like you know uh
fortunate to be able to afford it but
like
to me i don't have a fancy car i don't
even have a fancy home
but i got a housekeeper who comes you
know three days a week and i got a
private chef and to me that's like
that's my version of luxury that's like
you know that's my version of a lambo
it's like a lifestyle so does this
person tell me everything does this so i
had a chef as well for a minute but it
was a little bit different it was more
like meal prep does this person come and
i paid way less a fraction of that right
um i'm in the bay area too so you know
it's uh
yeah but my guy came two days a week and
they would meal prep for me and i didn't
like it i ended up just
not using them and i i made my own food
so
i tested so to do the sample idea i i
first even got the idea because i got to
sample it so my previous company monkey
furnace you've been there before for
lunch i think probably uh the the the
investors behind us they were kind of
like a billionaire family the the birch
family they had a private chef in their
home but you know they were out and
about all day working or they'd be at
the office so their chef would just come
to the office and cook for all of us and
so you know a company of like 20 people
and he would cook this amazing spread
and all of a sudden healthy food tasted
good so immediately i was like holy
this is kind of amazing i don't have to
like go out figure out what to eat every
day this guy just decides so that's one
decision i don't make he cooks healthy
food and it tastes like junk food all
right that's like you know wow that's
amazing if i just ate this for all my
meals i'd be way healthier than just my
lunch and so um so i got to sample it
that told me i want this um and there's
other things that i got to try you know
when i was at their house or fancy
parties that they throw or fancy cars
that they have
that you know i got to try and i was
like i i don't care about this good i
can scratch that off the list it's one
less thing i want it's one less thing i
care about and so that's just hanging
out with them got me got me to try some
things that i thought i was working for
and figure out what i like and don't
like
so then i tried some meal prep people
but what i figured out what i really
like is somebody who comes i don't
decide what to eat they know my they
know my
life they know what food i like they
know what what health what level of
healthiness i care about
and they just come make it fresh on the
spot because saying fresh food tastes
way better than meal prep food and so
she comes and she and then i also
thought i also realized oh this is not
just about my health like one of the
most time-consuming parts of being a
parent is constantly trying to feed your
kid like my kid's like a picky eater and
so she uh you know like i'm making like
three dishes for her every meal just
trying to get her to eat something that
she likes and that just takes up more
time than even cooking for myself did so
the chef cooks for me my wife who's
vegan and uh our our baby and so our
baby now eats like way better than when
we were just you know let's make some
mac and cheese let's warm something up
and um
and it makes it fun to feed five days a
week so i was tired so she so right now
she's coming three days a week uh so she
comes every other day basically and then
on the weekends we want to eat out so
we'd like to go to restaurants or
whatever so we said don't come on the
weekends and uh we may move it up to
five days at some point but right now
it's good basically and it's little
things like uh here's a green smoothie
she makes every you know so in between
meals instead of a snack it's she's like
oh you want your smoothie i'm like oh
yeah i do want that smoothie thank you
have you lost weight
uh i think so i don't really weigh
myself but in the mirror i look like you
lost weight i look better and i don't
know if my weight has changed i don't i
don't use the scale but i just use the
mirror as the scale and so often does
your cleaner come
three days a week also
and how much do you pay for that
160 bucks per visit i think
damn dude do you spend a lot of money on
these things i mean i spend a lot of
money on happiness they make me
extremely happy to do it but
they make like that the feeling after
the cleaners are here is like you know
that's like a high for me that's like i
did it i don't know what molly is but
that's molly for me i feel so good in my
own home it's amazing having food having
fresh healthy food made i think that's
that's a a treat that's an absolute
treat for me
i uh i'm perfectly happy with
we have a cleaner who comes every two
weeks and i think we spend 120 or 100 i
don't remember but
i'm also messy as and i have kids
and they're messy as so like you
know how the house gets destroyed uh you
know my sister cleans i think four times
a day in her house she's putting putting
toys away every you know every four
hours basically so it's crazy uh but i
don't know if people care about this but
i guess my my the point i'm trying to
make is i think samuel this episode is
already like totally ranked the world's
gonna
i think sampling your lifestyle is super
important i'll give you one more story
here that that helps so um you know that
uh i did a podcast from vegas i said i
was at somebody's home uh
you know 15 000 square feet yeah uh i
don't even know how many it's like ten
ten to fifteen thousand square feet just
it looks like a hotel basically
and uh unbelievable they they have a
they have a lambo and a ferrari and a
monster truck and like all this other
cool they have all the toys there's
a batting cage in the backyard there's a
you know like infinity pool that looks
over the city you know you can see the
strip there's like everything you would
want in a home they got it elevator all
the crazy um
and uh and so anyways when i was there i
had this feeling that i don't like that
i've thought i had slayed this feeling
but nope it came back and it was like
kind of like jealousy it was like i was
and the way i knew it was because i was
like kind of poo pooing like oh i don't
need all this i'm happy without all this
and i was kind of like in my head trying
to like almost say why i didn't want
these things because actually
i felt bad that i didn't have all these
things like this weird psychology thing
but the simple way of explaining it was
like i felt these like little hunger
pangs of envy of like oh i want that um
and i was like oh that's not a good
feeling and the shift i made was
uh instead of feeling like oh
you know these are things that i don't
have but they have right like it's
nothing wrong with them but just i don't
have these things and other people have
them um instead i looked at it
differently i was like uh by the the
third day there i i was like i gotta
shift my mindset i'm not trying to have
this jealousy feeling in my my day is
not a cool feeling for me so i was like
all right what am i gonna shift it to
and i said oh how about i look at this
like like i'm at i'm getting a sample
platter here so these are things i can
have these are things i can have in the
next few years you know things go right
in my business i can afford all these
things so why don't i feel like what it
feels like to wake up in a mansion like
this why don't i feel like what it's
like to to have a basketball court in a
batting cage you know built into the
home why don't i feel what it's like to
drive this car and oh now i'm all of a
sudden feeling excited what do i get to
try today that's like
you know i get to go try on something
that i might have in the future did you
did you drive this ferrari yeah so i get
to test drive the stuff and feel like
what like you know what does it feel
like you like it
no for me cars are stressful uh like i i
don't like fancy cars they're very
stressful to me and they're kind of like
uncomfortable like i don't really get
off on it there's probably a version of
a car that i like but not the like
supercars basically supercars are not
something i want and so i got to figure
out what do i not want and then oh
actually this feels really good it feels
really good to have you know this home
gym built into my home so okay you know
why don't i do that and you know why
don't i why don't i go for that then so
i think that sampling is not only just
an effective way to figure out what you
want it's also a cure for jealousy
because when you're in those situations
where you're jealous switch it to
thinking of it like i'm just getting to
try before i buy before i have all these
things i get to sample them and figure
out what exact flavor of this i'm gonna
want and then it becomes yours instead
of feeling like it's theirs and you
don't have it
i have that feeling with um so we had
this guy on the podcast a while ago we
should have him back on again his name
is nick bear
b-a-r-e nick bear he runs um bear
performance nutrition or some bpm and a
big youtube channel right
and a huge youtube channel this guy came
out with us he came out with this his
content production is so freaking good
so he's got this supplement business
that does like 20 or 30 million in
revenue a lot but when we had him on it
was like
6 million in revenue or something like
that it wasn't like it was good but it
wasn't significant and he created this
youtube channel he's like good looking
like yolk like he's a massive dude but
he so he lifts weights and he's this
muscle head but he's really cool and now
he's into endurance sports
and so on his youtube channel which now
when we had him on i think it had like
200 000 subscribers now it's getting
close to a million seven eight hundred
thousand he did this
thing he's got this whole team behind
his his youtube channel he's got like
three or four guys working full time on
it he released a 45 minute documentary
about him running the leadville 100 the
leadville 100 is a hundred mile race
through the mountains of leadville
colorado
and you basically i it looked like it
was like laps or something of like 15 or
20 miles and he had these guys at
checkpoints to film him and i was
watching this guy it was the most
inspirational i've ever seen i'm
gonna go and buy like i don't even know
what bear nutrition sells because
whenever i buy whey protein i just go to
whole foods and i just buy like you know
like uh or an amazon i'm purposely going
to go out of my way to buy his stuff
have you been paying attention to nick
bear i don't he doesn't show up on my
youtube feed i need to subscribe so it
starts to show up in my feed dude you
got to watch this guy it is the crate so
he's ex-military you're the only fitness
influencer i watch
we can talk about that in a second but
he this he's inspired me to like take it
to the gym yeah
he is so crazy this guy is nuts like
he has a video of him like dead lifting
550 pounds which is a ton of weight
and then he goes and he runs a marathon
in like 2 hours and 55 minutes which is
very very fast and he's the biggest guy
doing it it's very interesting so i've
been watching this guy and i have this
like pretty big sense of jealousy where
i'm like i want to be doing that and uh
so that's why i'm doing this little
fitness influencer now and it's
kind of a joke but not really a joke and
to be honest it's so fun dude you
totally have to do this it 100 makes you
accountable and makes you exercise
harder
yeah i love it i have to so i sampled
your gym so i went to your house sampled
your jam i was like wow amazing and then
i called you the other day i was like yo
what are you using for the flooring what
are you doing for this what are you
doing for that give me the give me the
the the blueprint because i'm turning my
garage into your garage i'm like that is
a great that was such an amazing feeling
to work out there i want to have that
feeling on a daily basis so dude it's
way cheaper than you think i know i
didn't even take it's not even a lot of
money but it's more like
it's more of having the clear vision of
what you want and seeing yours was like
oh now i know what i like and i just
have some addition some modifications
i'm like oh my daughter who's two she
loves to come out when i'm working out
and she loves to work out with me side
by side which is just like she just
wants to be she wants to do little
things next to me so we're creating a
little workout play pen
where she can go in there with little
foam weights and do her thing while i'm
doing mine so i'm like okay i'm going to
craft this lifestyle to be what i want
and um and so like you know that there's
something to this sampling and i really
encourage people to find a way to sample
it if you want to know what kind of home
you want go airbnb something before i
did this chef thing i hired a chef for
one meal to cook like a kind of a dinner
for like i had some friends in town he's
like oh let me hire somebody off
craigslist just to make one meal like i
don't want to deal with we can go out to
eat but wouldn't it be cool if a chef
came to our house and did it and like
the cost is about the same of you know
taking my friends out to a restaurant so
let me just do that at home it was
amazing and so uh having that chef at
the at the home was like a good way to
test these things and so
that's my kind of challenge to anybody
who has made it through this random
episode which is like
think about the that you have been
telling yourself you want and figure out
a way to go sample it like in the next
week go rent the car
go
hang out at someone's house go shadow a
ceo go you know hire the chef for the
day do do like the sample of it and
figure out does it make you want it 10
times more or 10 times less because
usually that's the reaction i have when
i when i feel it for the first time real
is i want it way more or way less
i'm curious if people are gonna like
this rambling um i like this stuff but i
don't know i wonder what what people
will enjoy because i could talk about
this all day i like this this
fitness crap this building the life that
you want crap i love this stuff
ben
chime in here what do you what do you
think ben
um i can only speak from like my
perspective which is
uh i'm really into the charter city
stuff so that like
i really liked that and the prison stuff
i think is gonna be interesting to
anyone so it worked for me and teddy
roosevelt i mean come on you knew that
would be are you gonna do dude teddy
roosevelt is the most prolific person i
have ever read about i've read
maybe over 100 biographies
he is
likely the most active person have ever
read uh he has done so much amazing
stuff this guy's a freak
teddy roosevelt's a fan where is it
where is the how to take over the world
episode on teddy roosevelt
of uh i would say of the people that
that people bring up that they want me
to do teddy roosevelt is probably number
two uh genghis khan probably number one
that people mention and teddy russell
number two so it'll dude roosevelt is
like he's different than napoleon like
napoleon did a lot but roosevelt is far
more eclectic he like before he was even
in politics when he was 21 he wrote a
book on the spanish-american war and it
was considered a textbook for decades um
and then he wrote a couple more books he
uh uh became um
uh president obviously that's amazing he
um was like this avid hunter and this
zoo
zoo what is it when you collect animals
and like uh describe like the
where they come from and things like
that like darwin he did that type
of crap before he was like in his 30s
very prolific very interesting person
you got to read about uh teddy roosevelt
very intriguing
what book are you reading the rise of
ted of teddy roosevelt
i think there's like three of them
because i know of them there's one that
came out
fairly recently is really popular now
about his trip to the amazon
um later in life
and that was amazing the guy was
ridiculous he also has this book that
i'm thinking about reading this title is
beautiful it's called a strenuous life
and so he had this phrase where he was
like so roosevelt would like even when
he was president every morning he would
box like fight box like spar he loved
and he was like it's our like we have to
live the strenuous life where we put in
effort physical effort and we get hurt
sometimes and we struggle he's like you
we have to do that otherwise you're
never going to feel like a man or or a
human being and so i've been very
inspired by teddy roosevelt very
interesting person
that's funny you know i'm listen ben i'm
listening to the vladimir putin episodes
that you did on the on how to take over
the world and uh i'm only i'm on part
one
and uh i love that he was like the
opposite of what you described because
when sam describes these people it's
like holy these are just like
another species it's like a guy who's
done this and this and this and this all
before the age of 30. and the best part
about the putin thing was you're like up
until 30 he basically had a very sort of
like average
average life there's nothing remarkable
that would tell you that this guy's
about to become what putin ended up
becoming it was like little hints little
signs a couple moments but
you know by and large it was like you
know mediocre mediocre student
you know
kind of like low level low level uh you
know spy
not not you know put in this like random
random office not in the high highest
level and then that was all until 30 and
then i'm guessing because i haven't
listened to part two yet but i'm
guessing that obviously it's gonna turn
up and he's gonna end up you know
becoming the leader leader of the
country but it was so crazy to me that
he was unremarkable essentially until
30. was that surprising to you
yeah and the the moment that you're
talking about is like he was kind of
like a mid-level operative in st
petersburg and i think the guy that he
worked for lost an election so he's like
out of a job and he was gonna go just
like start a judo gym in st petersburg
russia yeah because he's like pretty
good he sounded like just like he's
from the office he's like in scranton
he's just a mid-level he's assistant to
the regional manager and then somehow
becomes you know it's like if dwight
became elon musk that's sort of like
what happened with putin mid-level
officer to like you know
president
do you think ben that he is actually the
richest person in the world
um
[Music]
no
i don't in so far as like do i actually
think he has like
whatever a 100 billion dollars in secret
accounts probably not but it's like it
kind of doesn't matter because he has
access to as much money as he wants
whenever he wants yeah yeah yeah so he
probably just doesn't have to he like
doesn't have to move all that money to
his account does that mean he scares me
man so rich he doesn't need it in his
account
he freaks me out man putin scares the
out of me sam have you listened to
this episode of the putin one there's a
there's no i i i dude i i fear him and
so i've been nervous to listen to it
there's a line at the beginning that i
love those like it's like this little
little anecdote it's like he was kind of
like not a great student in school um
and just like wasn't very interesting
he's like he's the teacher's like he's
smart but he's not that interested in
school and so the teacher tells his dad
like you know he's not living up to he's
not living up to his potential
and the dad like as just like as a
russian dad would it's like most most
russian ever he goes
so what do i kill him or what do i do
that was the response
so what should i do kill him
i was like wow
the most russian thing ever
dude he's freaked me out man a lot of
the russians scare me that's kind of
like why i like khabib and the ufc's
because the russians like freak me out
they're on another level
they're on another level there's levels
to it let's just put it this way on one
level i've never seen a russian doing a
podcast
russians don't do podcasts right they
live a harder life than us
they're doing more and more tough
than than sitting in front of a
microphone dude i've never even seen a
russian smile
like they don't
like they don't i think i'm almost
positive they like
smiling and rushing those weaknesses if
you saw a russian and he winked at you
what would happen in your body
there's this comedian who like talks
about like he's like you know like one
time i was going to this bad
neighborhood and um i was nervous and i
wr and he was this guy's a white guy and
i was nervous and and he goes someone
came up to me talked to me and asked me
like a question that i thought that they
were just like trying to like trick me
into like uh you know testing me to see
where you know if they're gonna rob me
or not and he goes immediately i just
spoke at a russian accent and
immediately they were afraid afraid of
me and walked away and he's like this is
my defense mechanism he just says uh
dude of course i know like are you in
this like horrible rush like do i know
where i am of course do you like he like
says this like scary thing to this guy
and he like walks away from him entirely
and that's the defense mechanism from
now on it's just speaking of russian
accent
that's amazing if i do that in indian
accent i just get beat up on the spot so
it doesn't work the same um all right we
should wrap it up i just i was going to
say something i was going to stick up
for the russians a little bit i visited
russia with uh with my wife she speaks a
little bit of russian
and um
my experience was like they're they are
very much like that like they're kind of
gruff and like a little scary whatever
but there were a couple times where like
um
like my phone wasn't working and like we
needed to get to the train station in an
hour or else like we were gonna miss our
flight and everything go wrong and like
people were more willing to go out of
their way and like literally walk with
us for like five blocks make sure we
found the exact right spot than anywhere
else i've ever been so it's like they
have this very tough exterior but once
you get past it they're like and
obviously we're joking if you are
russian we have love for you but we're i
thought we were complimenting the whole
time i was saying don't poison sam don't
feel sad i was saying how badass they
are
everything i said i stand behind as a
compliment uh you know even just the
cities dude st petersburg do we have
anything on the level of the word moscow
saint peter's these just sound tougher
than american cities right like whenever
i hear the word the kremlin or kremlin
i'm like i freak out
yeah
exactly kremlin scary words bro we have
like tampa bay it's this is not
comparable what we have you know it's
just they're on another level of
toughness
like denver
can you imagine
just put it just put denver up against
moscow
america america is just not where it's
at all right i gotta go i'm just before
i get canceled for for praising the
russians
[Music]
you